i was born in bangladesh
i grew up in the us i have lived in
chicago new york los angeles i've been
coming to dubai for a while to see the
culture of middle east i like the
diversity in dubai it's a melting pot
and if i can do something gastronomic
that is new and exciting here it's
fulfilling
[Music]
my name is mohammed islam i am a cook
now i live in dubai
i was trained in classic french cuisine
i love french food that's my passion
it's very easy to live here and i really
like the local people they're extremely
humble dubai kind of drew me back here
due to the
the growth of the country plus i like
the diversity because we have somewhere
around 200 nationalities here and
it's very hard to find anywhere in the
world
atelierm is a creation between the food
and the design
so we use classic techniques to create
modern cuisine
i have at least eight different
nationalities in the kitchen so when we
sit down and brainstorm putting together
the culture diversity we come up with
things that i would never able to think
about and when you see food is coming
out beautifully from the kitchen it's a
great feeling the synergy all the chefs
working together it's like a family
one good thing in dubai that you can get
everything from east as well as west so
i have japan very close to me i have
australia it's not too far then i have
entire europe
for every chef i think the produce
locally it's very very important and i
think that's where it gives you the
colors
of our plate
i think my vision was right today dubai
is one of the top food cities you can
say
internationally recognized chefs are in
dubai creating modern cuisine
there is plenty of great restaurants all
around dubai which compete with the rest
of the world today
why do i love food
i think food is everything food is
entangled with culture
culture is society and society is all of
us
you